Let us now go
through an example.
Suppose that we have an
unknown random variable
Theta that has a uniform
distribution between 4 and 10.
We observe some
other random variable
X that's related
to Theta according
to the following model.
This is the conditional
distribution of X given Theta.
For any given value
of theta, X is
going to take values between
theta minus 1 and theta plus 1.
And the conditional distribution
is uniform on that range.
One way of thinking about this
particular observation model
is that what we observe
is the true value
of Theta plus some noise term.
And this noise term is
uniform on the range
from minus 1 to plus 1.
So given a value
of Theta, we may
observe anything, because
of noise, that's up to one
lower or one higher than
the true value of Theta.
And if we take this description,
actually, this random variable
U has this distribution
no matter what Theta is.
And therefore, U is
independent of Theta.
But in any case, this particular
interpretation will not matter.
Let us see how do we proceed.
In Bayesian estimation,
the first step
is always to put our
hands on the posterior
distribution of Theta.
And to find the
posterior, we can
start by first
finding the joint.
So let us look at
the x theta plane.
That's where the joint
distribution is going to live.
And our first step
will be to locate
those values of X and
Theta that are possible,
given our description.
From this model here, we
know that theta minus 1
is going to be less
than or equal to x.
And x is going to be less
than or equal to theta plus 1.
And we translate this
into two inequalities,
namely that theta is less
than or equal to x plus 1,
and from here, that
theta is larger
than or equal to x minus 1.
So these are the
constraints that we
have on the possible
values of x and theta.
So here we plot the line where
theta is equal to x plus one.
And here we plot
the line on which
theta is equal to x minus 1.
And these two inequalities
that we've got here
tell us that we need to live
somewhere in between those two
lines.
In addition, we have
the fact that theta
lives between 4 and 10.
And that places these
two limits as well.
So to summarize, this
shape here is the set
off all possible x's and thetas.
Outside this shape, the joint
PDF is going to be zero.
What is it going
to be inside here?
Well, because the
prior is uniform,
that is, it is constant, and
the model is also uniform,
to obtain the joint
we multiply these two.
And since they are
constant, we obtain
a joint that's also constant.
So the joint PDF is equal
to a constant over that set.
We can easily calculate
the area of this set.
It is 12.
So the joint is equal to
1 over 12 inside this set.
And of course, it's 0 elsewhere.
So we have a uniform joint PDF.
Now, let us look
at the posterior.
If I tell you that X takes
on this specific value,
this means that we now
live in this universe.
And it means that all of
those thetas are possible.
The posterior
distribution is going
to be a distribution
that tells us
the probabilities of
these different thetas.
What kind of distribution is it?
Well, we know that the
conditional is just
a section out of the joint
but keeps, otherwise,
the same shape.
Since the joint is constant,
it's uniform over that set,
it means that the posterior,
or the conditional,
is also constant over that set.
So the conclusion is that the
posterior distribution of Theta
is a uniform
distribution on this set.
Given this knowledge, what is
the conditional expectation?
The conditional
expectation of a uniform
is just the midpoint
of that uniform.
And so this is going to
be our estimate of Theta,
the conditional
expectation of Theta,
given the observation
that we have obtained.
And then a similar
argument applies no matter
what x we have obtained.
For any given x, our
estimate is going
to be the midpoint of the
corresponding interval.
So what kind of shape
do we get by doing this,
by joining the mid-points?
It's going to be a straight
line over this region.
It's also going to be a
straight line over this region
except that, because
of the change in shape,
it's going to be a straight
line with a different slope.
And similarly, in
this region, it's
also going to be a straight
line with a different slope.
So what have we plotted here?
For any given
value of X, we have
plotted the corresponding
conditional expectation
of Theta given that value of
X. And as a function of x, this
gives us a certain curve.
And this blue curve
that we have calculated
is a particular function of x.
And we can think
of this function g
as being our estimator.
So the way we're
going to be processing
the data will be that
whenever we obtain an x,
we apply this
particular function g.
And we come up with an estimate.